nachdem ich unser büro umgebaut habe und
so die ersten einblicke ins handwerk
gewinnen konnte konnte ich mich immer
mehr dafür begeistern um euch auch dafür
zu begeistern habe ich mich mit macher
gesucht eine aktion des bayerischen
handwerkstags zusammengetan um gemeinsam
für euch content zu produzieren
kannst du einmal klatschen
wir haben handwerker aus verschiedenen
bereichen eingeladen und ihnen
verschiedene fragen gestellt und das
waren ihre antwort und
22 jahre alt
hallo mein
name ist ich bin azubi
maurer beruf hallo ich bin ich bin
fotograf und bin jetzt im letzten
lehrjahr service ich bin der tu noch
eine ausbildung als zweiradmechaniker
hanna und ich bin
also ich bin der daniel heim ich arbeite
als anlagenmechaniker shk als meister
christoph mit kunst mein name ist und
metzgermeister was ist die größte
herausforderung in deinem beruf ich
glaube mir selber gerecht zu werden weil
ich die meisten ansprüche wahrscheinlich
an mich selber habe und am anfang von
der ausbildung definitiv nach hilfe
fragen ich denke sich auf spiegel.de
kunden einzustellen ich habe keine
ahnung 20 kunden am tag und ich muss
mich jeden tag jedes mal nur auf die
kunden einstellen eigentlich hat keinen
fall wieder andere das heißt ich habe
auch jeden tag aufs neue die größte
herausforderung ist die vielseitigkeit
würde ich was sogar sagen dass man sich
in allen möglichen bereichen auskennen
sollte jetzt gerade als meister und mit
dem kunden anspruch und mit der
nachhaltigkeit und dem tirol dass wir
die perfekt verbindet und für den kunden
einfach das bestmögliche produkt aus und
welche tipps hast du für junge leute die
noch nicht genau wissen welchen beruf
sie ausüben wo viele praktika machen
viele praktikas hälfte unbedingt
praktikers machen sich die berufe
anschauen direkt auch mit dabei sein
könnt ihr euch ausprobiert viel
ausprobieren sagt es ist immer schwierig
herauszufinden was ist das was ich immer
machen will kann halt einfach auf ihr
bauchgefühl wenn ihr das nämlich gut
findet dann wird zumindest gut warum ist
das handwerk im allgemeinen als
berufsfeld zu empfehlen
das schwierig ich hatte nach der schule
nicht so bock direkt noch weiter schule
zu machen oder jetzt zu studieren ich
wollte irgendwie was arbeiten und was
machen was leute kennenlernen dafür ist
das auf jeden fall das richtige das ist
ein job der niemals ausstirbt wir werden
gebraucht niemand weiß wie man etwas
repariert weil sie sichere arbeitsstelle
ist definitiv wir werden im handwerk
braucht es wird immer da sein immer
beständig sein
weil man darf für sich selber einfach so
die berufung finden kann letztendlich
darf man nicht vergessen dass wir die
meiste zeit seines lebens in der arbeit
verbringen das muss einfach keinen spaß
morgen erfüllen und da bietet das
handwerk einfach unwahrscheinlich viele
möglichkeiten unter diesen spektrum das
handwerk ich finds halt sehr interessant
wenn man sieht was man tut man macht aus
den händen man sieht ein ergebnis und
sitzt nicht vom pc am abend ein zu gehen
und sagen das habe ich getan ich habe
ein schönes bad gebaut kann mich in die
badewanne legen und kann es mir gut
gehen lassen erinnerst du dich an das
lustigste erlebnis aus seinem
arbeitsalltag eigentlich jeder tag den
arbeitskollegen und lustig bei uns in
einem in der metzgerei da muss natürlich
auch immer alles tipptopp sauber sein
muss er wirklich gut gereinigt werden
und beim ersten tag dann kam ich mit
diesem reinigungsgerät jetzt so gut klar
und mein chef stand direkt erleben dass
ist so mit dem rücken zu mir und ich
habe das irgendwie nicht so auf die
kette gebracht und dann war da nach
unten
also wir arbeiten mit klebstoffen und in
meinem ausbildungsbetrieb hat mir so
holzbretter wo hat immer die sachen ein
gestrichen worden sind und dann hatte
ich das feuerzeug hand hier bei
schnellem einen faden abgebrannt habe
und hat sich dann in diesem thread in
flammen
also wir haben in der berufsschule haben
wir mal
video geschnitten und da haben wir so
ein kommen die ausbildung video gemacht
von wegen kommen in die gruppe und haben
das ziemlich witzig zusammengeschnitten
das hat spaß gemacht ist während einer
ausbildung schon mal irgendwas richtig
doofe es passiert und wenn ja wie wurde
damit umgegangen ist richtig schlimm ist
dass wir gleich noch nicht passiert aber
in der berufsschule habe ich mal eine
kamera vom stativ geworfen wurde kurz
drüber geredet aber nichts weiter
passiert nichts groß
das war wie eine bratwurst gemacht und
ich habe irgendwie das salz vergessen
war ich der schlüsselprobleme in dem
moment auf fehler seien ja gut ohne
fehler kontinent dazu ja das sind die
wichtigsten dinge überhaupt in der
ausbildung ist und das zeichen das
handwerk auch einfach aus also man kann
aus dieser situation trotzdem wir das
beste machen und dann wird einfach was
neues hergestellt und da sind wir halt
einfach den vielen anderen berufen man
einfach voraus wie werden lehrlinge in
deinem bereich auf die schippe genommen
per klassisches siemens luft sagen jeder
kennt das war so einer wasserwaage es
lehrt fühlst dann wieder auch mal die
handschuhe punkt wurde so dass man das
gelenk buch bei uns ist ja so wir
zerlegen ja die tiere vor ort und da
gibt es eine person kniffe und tricks
die man einfach kennen und wissen muss
dass das leicht von der hand geht und da
gibt es eigentlich kein bug dafür aber
jeder art zu bieten dabei ist und der
das gut mitmacht auch der musste es dann
holen wir sind die karrierechancen im
handwerk du kannst nicht immer weiter
entwickeln natürlich machst du dann
gesehen als erstes und danach hast du
möglichkeiten noch seinen meister zu
machen du kannst danach studieren
könnten ingenieur machen irgendwann
hatte auch den möglichkeiten sich
selbstständig immer wieder zu machen und
muss man einfach wirklich sorgen muss
dass wir an handwerksberuf erlernt hat
hat man von der pike auf einfach auf
nachhaltigkeit und und das arbeiten
gelernt intelligent seine fähigkeiten zu
verknüpfen und es ist unwahrscheinlich
wertvoll fürs leben denn fast das beste
beispiel dafür ich bin eine junge frau
ich musste nur 20 ich habe meine
ausbildung mit 16 angefangen mit 24
meisterin und ich leide eine filiale
deswegen würde ich sagen ja das handwerk
bietet einen einfach extrem große
chancen warum geht ohne das handwerk
nicht mehr repariert bei der heizung
sonst so
verbrauchen van treeck weil die aber zu
können macht dann wenn es uns nicht
geben würde dann würde vieles ziemlich
schlampig und herunter geht dann
ausschauen wie wichtig ist das handwerk
für den klimaschutz also interessante
frage ja einfach die dinge neu
aufzubereiten parkettboden zb
abschleifen nicht ausreichenden alten
sondern gleich verschneiten also der
klimaschutz ist wichtig und durch die
farbe da kann man das glaube ich ganz
gut abdecken schreibt zum beispiel der
kam nachjustiert werden also repariert
werden muss nicht weggeworfen werden und
man kann immer wieder verwenden wenn ich
jetzt daheim geguckt da habe ich einen
schwank aus meiner stehen und seitdem
weiß ich dass aus dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert und sucht man nach einem
ikea regal haben für mich eigentlich so
der inbegriff der nachhaltigkeit das
waren einfach viel viel länger halten
also ich habe leute die pflegen ihre
gegen ihre schuhe die ich gebaut habe
dann halten die schuhe 10 20 jahre
beschreiben deinen beruf in drei
kreativität kommunikation direkte
resultate
lustig abwechslungsreich und eine
challenge kreativ detailreich
anspruchsvollen individuell kreativ und
vielseitig anstrengend lustig und liebst
nur was neues
individualität lebensqualität also sehr
abwechslungsreich ist auf jeden fall mit
dabei kann auch anstrengend sein aber es
ist macht einfach spaß die ergebnisse zu
sehen leidenschaft herzlichkeit rohstoff
frische
das war's ich hoffe ihr hattet spaß wenn
ja lasst den video gerne ein leichter
und vergesst natürlich nicht jetzt euren
traumberuf über den ersten link in der
video beschränkt
[Musik]